وفي اول ايام عيد الاضحى المبارك ابدى
حجاج بيت الله طوافى الافاضه في المسجد
الحرام ليعودوا بعد ذلك الى منى حيث يبتون
ايام التشريق التي يقومون خلالها باستكمال
رمي الجمرات كانت افواج الحجاج قد تحركت
منتصف الليل وقبل فجر اليوم من مشعل
مزدلفه متجهين الى منى لرمي الجمره الكبرى
ومن ثم طواف الافاضه وذلك في ختام ابرز
محطات مناسك الحج هذا العام الذي شهد
مشاركه اكثر من مليون وثمانمائه الف حاج
وزاره الصحه السعوديه اعلنت عن تسجيل اكثر
من 6500 حاله اجهاد حراري بين الحجاج في
موسم هذا العام والوزاره نشرت قبيله بدايه
موسم الحاج عده تحذيرات للحجاج من التعرض
لاشعه الشمس قدر الامكان وعدم الوقوف صفوف
الانتظار لمده طويله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات